Carnegie Mellon University has partnered
with the Tony Awards for the second
annual excellence and theater Education
Award so I went to a very small private
school Shore crest prep in st.
Petersburg Florida
only a couple hundred people in my high
school everybody knew everybody and it
was and we became active in thespians my
sophomore year between my parents and a
couple of my teachers Leo lien who was
one of my high school drama teachers my
aunt Ginny stringer was also one of my
drama teachers they fostered this desire
to not only follow your dreams but that
this was a viable career and you should
treat it like a career and I've always
been so passionate about theater
education because I always use this
analogy if you want to be a doctor you
don't just go hang out at a hospital you
have to do the work
you